tomemos la serie infinita
que suman los términos desde que n es
igual a 1 hasta infinito y cuyos
términos son 1 entre 2 a la n + n bueno
entonces tenemos esta serie y queremos
saber si converge o diverge y cómo te
puedes imaginar dado el contexto en el
que se encuentra este vídeo en la página
de khan academy que vamos a intentar
hacerlo con el criterio de comparación y
en cualquier momento si en algún punto
de este vídeo sientes que puedes tú
terminar de resolver este ejercicio
ponle pausa al vídeo y terminarlo tú en
fin vamos paso a paso y bueno siempre
que tenemos una serie para tener un poco
de intuición acerca de cómo funciona
esta serie es buena idea sustituir los
primeros valores de n así es que vamos a
ver el primer término de esta serie
cuando n es igual a 1 es uno entre 2 a
la 1
+ 1 o sea o sea que el primer término es
un tercio y el segundo término cuando n
es igual a 2 es 1 / 2 a la 2 o sea 2 al
cuadrado que es 4 + 2 426 o sea que
tenemos aquí un sexto más el tercer
término cuando n es igual a 31 entre 2 a
la 32 a la 38 más 13
eso es 11 o sea 1 entre 11 y bueno vamos
a hacer un último término el término 4
así es que me tiene que ser igual a 4 y
tenemos 1 entre 2 a la 4 2 a la 4 es 16
más 4 tenemos 20 o sea que tenemos un
veinteavo y bueno por aquí faltan un
montón de términos de hecho falta una
infinidad
de términos pero bueno si observamos
estos términos
todos estos términos y cualquier término
de estos cuando sustituyamos cualquier n
en esta fórmula
todos estos términos son mayores que 0 y
al parecer cada término que sacamos es
considerablemente más chico que el
anterior como que esta serie si se está
haciendo muy chiquita y pareciera que si
convergen bueno si nos ponemos a
analizar esta fórmula que nos da el
valor de cada término de esta serie pues
aquí en el denominador tenemos todos a
la n + n y sabemos que 2 a la n crece
muchísimo más rápido que m entonces a
final de cuentas estos términos
van a terminar comportándose muchísimo
más como 1 entre 2 a la n iv eso nos da
una pista de qué tipo de serie podemos
utilizar para comparar con esta serie de
aquí ok entonces vamos a poner por aquí
la serie desde que en es igual a 1 hasta
infinito de 1 entre 2 a la n iv bueno
vamos a poner los primeros términos 1
entre 2 a la 1 es 1 / 2 más el segundo
término es uno entre 4 + 1 entre 8 más 1
entre 2 a la 4 que es uno entre 16 y
bueno también esto tiene una infinidad
de términos y podríamos seguir y seguir
y seguir poniendo términos pero lo
interesante aquí es que podemos
reconocer esta serie no o sea esta serie
es una serie geométrica esto de aquí
geométrica
triká y bueno podríamos escribirlo de
forma que sea más claro que esto es una
serie geométrica podemos escribirlo como
la suma desde que en es igual a 1 hasta
infinito de 1 entre 2 elevado a la n iv
lo que hemos visto acerca de las series
geométricas es que si el valor absoluto
de este número de aquí si el valor
absoluto de un medio es menor que 1 lo
cual si sucede entonces la serie
geométrica esta serie
zuma desde el 1 hasta infinito de 1 / 2
a la n converge
con
bergé porque el valor absoluto de un
medio es menor que 1 y esta es una serie
geométrica y bueno como es una serie
geométrica de hecho hasta tenemos una
fórmula que nos dice exactamente cuánto
vale esta serie aunque entonces tenemos
que esta serie convergen y tenemos que
todos estos términos
todos estos términos son mayores o
iguales que 0 y bueno estos términos
tienen un denominador más chico que
estos términos por lo cual cada uno de
estos términos es más grande que el
término correspondiente de estos
términos y se nota mucho en esto de aquí
o sea un medio es más grande que un
tercio y un cuarto es más grande que un
sexto y un octavo también es más grande
que un onceavo así es que cumplimos con
todas las hipótesis del criterio de
comparación vamos a ver por aquí tenemos
esto es lo que habíamos escrito el
criterio de comparación las hipótesis y
las cumplimos todos los términos son
mayores o iguales que cero
y todos los términos de esta serie son
mayores o iguales que los términos de
esta serie
así es que podríamos decir que en el
criterio de comparación
esta serie de aquí es la serie morada es
la serie pequeña y esta otra serie de
aquí es la serie grande ok bueno ya la
había pintado de azul pero bueno el
chiste es que como ésta es una serie
geométrica sabemos que convergen que
ésta converge con bergé y eso implica
que esta serie de aquí que se queda
atrapada entre el 0 y la serie grande
que convergen entonces esta serie
también converge
con bergé